so we're going to hop up here and then
they're going to raise it up
oh oh boy here we go we're going up
[Music]
all right you guys this
is something very exciting this is the
microsoft
surface hub and i guess we're in our
pandemic bubbles we actually saw the
large version of this
at ces this year and today my friends
hold on we are going to unbox the
50-inch version
and it is now going to be a part of my
home and my studio in my life
i wasn't prepared look at this little
thing what do you actually think you're
going to do with that hey yeah can we
show can we show them something first
because this is cool
come here we have about those first look
at this this is high technology called
tip and tail it's uh blue beads they
indicate
you know this is mishandled but we're
good
just gonna tip and tell myself
dude you're gonna stab me
[Music]
this is like a hamster unboxing like if
i was a hamster
like this is a box that i would unbox
okay this is so small
are you kidding me oh that's a usbc
fingerprint reader hey put this in your
pocket my pockets are full
oh should i start oh can i should i open
this stuff
up do you want to open it there or do
you want to open it
should i open some house so sean had a
really good idea
he said why don't we time lapse the
delivery people putting it together
we just don't want to waste their time
you know they know what to do
[Music]
it's here okay what's the plan here well
so here's the instructions we pull the
pin here we go
whoa
wait wait do i move this i should
probably move this and put it right here
but it has a cart so basically we can
move it wherever we want
oh well we've got a camera and
this looks like one of like the crayola
markers that you get like as a child so
you could be like
simple cable okay well i gotta i think i
need to lock this
out yes so this says that we um
pick it up with two people one two
that's oh that's not in english read the
ones that are
okay oh read here look some of it's in
english and some of it's not
true i know it's it's life is hard
whoa okay okay that's cool
all right okay oh i did top first i did
two
there we go that makes sense i did round
one first cool
whoa this is cool oh my goodness
oh my gosh i'm gonna start having um
lectures
oh look at this look at this peel this
is so cool
look how clean it is oh no
[Applause]
wow whoa
this can be the snack table oh my
goodness definitely the snack table
that'll be for appetizers mikko nookie
it's like you're at the groomer
oh okay okay beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep
careful obstacle oh this is a perfect
fit
we had something here wait i have a
better view than you do
wait a minute what there's
secrets yeah that's what we're gonna be
housing the
snacks wow
jenna remember that little thing that i
have it stick it in
gsbc doesn't matter at least i don't
think so i don't i actually don't know
that looks like the right way that looks
like it's in there
that looks like a power button to me
there you go oh my gosh here we go
hi i'm cortana a little touch of wi-fi
here little sign in there jenna hello so
everything's set up we've got the
product key entered we've got
everything up and running we've got some
apps but oh we're gonna order dinner now
so i've got elefante up this is like our
favorite restaurant it's
so good i'm gonna sit on the couch get a
full menu experience
absolutely yeah we can't be
oh gosh this is incredible oh
premium we are now in the menu
um jenna yes please pay attention
oh wow here's the whipped eggplant you
can't really see that sea salt i'm gonna
have to ask them to up their resolution
on their images because this is
this we're talking about we've got a 4k
display here we need high quality images
on
doordash oh i can almost taste that
delicious delicious bread i think we're
going to need to do
at least two orders okay we'll do two
orders okay who's up next
[Music]
food is ordered now it's time to draw
the food that i ordered
so let's see oh oh that's my first mark
isn't it cool that you can just flip the
pen over and it erases yeah practical
it's super practical okay so jenna what
did we say what we want i got the
rigatoni pomodoro
it's like a bowl shape maybe yeah oh my
gosh
what is that i don't have a cup here's
the plate
it's like oh look at that like a little
oh like that if i don't press very hard
it makes a small line well it's not
spaghetti
you just said spaghetti pomodoro
rigatoni
i hate this it's spaghetti now
[Music]
so we're about to get some training now
so we can learn everything that there is
to know about this
we wait for dinner
[Music]
so the surface hub 2 is honestly really
cool and
realistically this is definitely not
something that i feel like a lot of
people are going to have in their homes
but i do see a future where
now people are working from home so
often that companies will be putting
things like this
into the homes of their employees
because it really is a one-stop shop to
be able to sync up with your team and
obviously one of the things that i love
is the whiteboard feature so there's a
few different features in whiteboard
that are kind of cool there's this ink
to shape
which will basically just allow you to
create beautiful shapes
without really doing any type of effort
at all
one of the things i love about the
whiteboard is how expansive it is i can
just scroll over here and start working
on something else
i want to show you guys ink to table so
when you have that turned on you can use
your pen
to make a spreadsheet so check this out
oh look at that spreadsheet
spreadsheet spreadsheet
cool food
um yes or no
cheese burger
[Music]
that's really ugly i'm gonna erase it
cheeseburger yes grilled cheese yes
pancakes
yes salad just for the sake of this
video i'm gonna say no
but i do love salad whoa check this out
when you click that little magic
wand it cleans up your handwriting
no way i wonder if i can take a picture
of myself oh i can look at that
okay ready i'm gonna try to jump and
take the photo at the same time
oh heck yeah look at this
it's so silly i mean look at that it's
beautiful it's a hat that's my hat
one of the main highlights though of
whiteboard is the collaboration aspect
of it so you can invite your team your
friends
to work on the same document with you so
that's definitely something for
businesses
where i can see this is such a huge
asset but for us we're gonna of course
be making a lot of spreadsheets
about food but like the maps on this
look so amazing so right now we're in
new york and
with the pen you're able to draw and
it'll give you the distance and the
current time that it will take
to go that distance oh you actually took
me a completely different route because
that's the way that you should go to get
there you can also do just basic marking
up
so one of the things from using this
that i kind of was struggling a little
bit with is the keyboard because the
keyboard is kind of large and sometimes
you do have to hit it
down here to bring it up you can move it
around and stuff like that but you can
also
hook up an external keyboard or a mouse
or anything like that so any other io
that you have
it will work with this another cool
thing you can do is if you have a
surface you're
actually able to mirror that display or
you could duplicate it side by side so
be able to project your surface display
onto the surface hub 2 or you can
actually control the surface hub 2 with
your surface
uh you know what i have hooked up to
this oh that's right
we've got the xbox series x and there's
a bunch of different
inputs that we have here so if we just
push this little input button
this will take us to hdmi okay i haven't
played in a while so
let's just let's not judge
oh my god i'm terrible
i'll just grind some rails maybe
oh i did a kick flip
i feel like this is definitely going to
be one of the most widely used features
in the surface hub well guys thank you
so much for watching this was so fun to
get a chance to check this out a huge
thank you to microsoft for hooking me up
with one of these to test
this is so fun since i did just get my
hands on this i haven't fully got a
chance to
really test it out extensively but this
is now all part of the family so i would
like you to say welcome
welcome there is one more little
addition that i'm waiting for
this actually has a battery pack so
you're able to add the battery pack onto
this stand
and then i can freely roam around my
house with this
that is definitely something that i
never knew i needed
and now that it's almost here i can't
wait
[Music]
you